but my crypto guest says that the next
one million years is all about bitcoin
and crypto joining me now bitcoin expert
leia halpern along with euro pacific
capital chief uh chief economist peter
marisa uh you know i'm glad to have you
both let me start with you leah uh
bitcoin taking it on the chin here a
little bit uh you know and some of the
arguments uh uncorrelated hedge against
inflation a flight to safety those
haven't worked lately what do you say to
people who are saying maybe it was
overhyped
well actually i think it's exactly
working put the price away just for a
second if you actually understand the
fundamental value of bitcoin it's
working perfectly let's go to canada for
example and the government behaves
authoritarian and decided to freeze the
bank accounts of freedom protesters as a
result people can literally start
trading peer-to-peer and bitcoin you
can't trade peer-to-peer and gold
bitcoin is literally an alternative
monetary system it really is a medium of
exchange nobody is trading when um you
know for goods and services in gold also
a really important point to make as well
is when it comes to donating and
actually helping these people people
have donated nearly half a million it's
probably more um in bitcoin to um the
canadian um truckers and then also if
you go to ukraine it's also very
important to realize that the same kind
of category
capital controls are happening right
peter the same type of capital controls
are happening and so people are actually
donating i think it's around 4.4 million
dollars wow uh peter i mean and to be
honest gold hasn't done much in the last
decade uh is looking better these days
but
you know the same arguments that that
leia just laid out you used to use for
buying gold has it just shifted i mean
is the rationale for wanting to have an
alternative to the dollar seal there but
maybe it's no longer gold
no we definitely need alternatives to
the dollar and there are many ways to
hedge against inflation but bitcoin is
not one of them
bitcoin is not going to hedge against
anything it's just a highly speculative
token it's basically a digital pyramid
ponzi scheme it went up for a while uh
but people are using it primarily to
gamble with people are betting that the
price is going to go up except now the
price is falling in fact year over year
the price of bitcoin is down and it may
be going uh a lot lower it doesn't have
any uh fundamental intrinsic value like
gold it's not a business it doesn't pay
a dividend like a stock it's not real
estate you can't rent it out it's not a
bond it it it's like a it's a digital
beanie baby except you know you can't
snuggle up with it it doesn't look cute
on your bed but what's the argument for
buying gold though i mean okay you laid
out your the reasons you don't like
bitcoin but
what's the argument now at this stage
for buying gold uh you know that has
been an underperformer for a long time
well not a long time because remember uh
from 2001 to 2011 the price of gold went
up from under 300 to almost 2 000. so
when you have that kind of move over a
decade and from 2011 to 2021
it didn't do much
correct it's consolidated and now it's
getting ready for another big run-up as
a result of all the inflation that has
been created over the past decade and
the inflation that's going to be created
during the coming decade i think gold is
very cheap relative to the amount of
dollars in circulation i think the
technical picture looks very bright for
gold as does the fundamental picture i
think we've now had a big blow up in
inflation for a while people thought
there was no inflation then they thought
it was transitory and now they think the
fed is going to fight it they're wrong
again the fed can't fight inflation
because we have too much debt inflation
is going to get worse and people are
going to look for hedges and gold is
going to be one of the hedges they
choose not bitcoin leah
well i think you said bitcoin isn't
really doing anything right now bitcoin
is actually saving people's lives people
are fleeing war-torn ukraine they're
actually leaving to go to poland are
they taking their gold billion bars
absolutely not and even if they did get
to the uh get to the border people are
absolutely corrupt if they get to the
border authorities could say sorry can i
have one of those gold bullion bars and
and only let you win in that case so you
don't really want to be snuggling up
with your bitcoin nobody wants to know
that you own bitcoin that's the
fundamental value you can flee tyranny
and right now you can flee um you know
lockdowns you can flee vaccine mandates
whatever it is your government is
throwing at you you can flee that with
the keys in your head nobody needs to
know what you own and i certainly will
not be fleeing any kind of dangerous
tyrannical government with gold billion
bars peter but the vast majority of
people who are buying bitcoin are not
buying it for that reason they're buying
bitcoin because they think the price is
going to go up and when they stop
thinking the price is going to go up
they're going to sell and when enough
people want to sell and there's nobody
to buy the price is going to collapse
and you know this whole argument that is
a store of value is going to evaporate
because you can't store something you
don't have bitcoin has no underlying
value like gold which is a metal a
valuable metal that's used for all sorts
of things bitcoin isn't used for
anything other than speculation and it's
only being used for speculation because
people think it's going to go up well if
they stop thinking that because it's
going down then there is no reason to
own it yes there you you come up with
these small examples but that's a tiny
fraction of the demand for bitcoin and
once the price crashes that demand will
go away too leah
but you've been saying the price is
gonna crash for um you know years now i
follow you on twitter i've been seeing
what you've been saying and i mean if
you look at the last five years gold is
actually up only around 39 it's not
really done anything whereas bitcoin is
up thousand two hundred percent perhaps
we live in an entirely new era and in a
new time where my generation millennials
actually do see value in something which
is digital rather than something which
is tangible
you know all young generations make all
young generations make mistakes bitcoin
has crashed many times over the last
five years
every time it comes back pretty strong
we got it we gotta leave it there but if
it doesn't always come back charles one
time it's gonna crash and never come
back all right let's leave it there too
passionate folks peter leia thank you
both very much